you're into meditation I could guess you
are into meditation you see and I know
that that's not a put-down in any way
you seem like the most centered calm guy
I've met in in the history of my life I
think you are you're very calm and
you're very centered I can't be but you
know the center I tried to get the
center as large as possible here looking
at these guys I'm kind of kind of
getting excited about doing a little Oh
me what do you think owning already the
camera guys owe me yeah okay so here's
how we have to do it one of the tricks
is that we're all human beings your
human eye and our lung capacities are
the same relatively so we got to stagger
the thing so the homing you know can
carry on and so I'm going to kind of
direct you guys when to ohm okay so
we're gonna like a row row row your boat
start with you okay all right sure of
course
okay you ready ah
Oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
your show
before what you think you get up do you
guys like that get you I was painting
the entire time thinking is I got it
where we going what's happening yeah
he's not that was not calm for me at all
no see but that's the cool thing about
stress stop touching me
great I'm gonna find my Center great
back we'll talk to Jeff Bridges
you